hi and welcome to episode number 21 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendell hey Mark hey
friends sku doing today pretty good a
little bit tired after all these weeks
of a lot of action but yeah very excited
about the interviews today yeah we're
going to have some conversations
recorded back at GSP next couple of
weeks ago now talking to the people from
instrument who did the demos at the
event yeah so we interviewed three
people from instrument we interviewed
John Brown which is a technical director
violet Pena which is that worked on
vision API for a very cool day mother
mother booth and then Nick the Paris
that worked on the query it which is a
demo using bigquery yeah it's pretty
awesome demos I think it's going to be
really interesting to hear like how they
explored the api's and use the products
and what they learned and what worked
and what didn't yeah those are all very
beautiful demos like I you can tell that
they're pros at this but also they're
really interesting on the way they use
our product so I think it's going to be
very interesting conversations yep most
definitely and after that we'll have a
question of the week and today it's
about deployment manager yeah we're
going to have a look at how you can use
variables and deployment manager thinks
the first time we ever say the words
deployment manager I think so yeah so
excited about that too definitely but
first let's go with a cool thing of the
week so we're going to be talking about
stat driver error reporting so what's
new on that so as of a blog post that
came out yesterday we're pretty excited
to announce that yay if you need a
service to basically aggregate and
collate the areas that are happening
with your within your application and
you know I guess they're probably some
I'm sure everyone else is in there and
our audiences applications are
completely perfect and never error out
mine are perfect I believe so um so
while we've had log aggregation for a
really long time you generally also want
some kind of service to be like hey
liezel all these errors happen together
they're all happening at the same time
maybe only send you a notification when
a new one pops up it handles those sort
of things like where is
coming from all that sort of stuff it's
it's a lot easier to sort of powers than
be like uh you know let's go through the
logs looking for keywords things like
that it's pretty cool and right now it's
in beta so you know it comes for free
which is pretty sweet if you're using
App Engine though you get it for free
you don't have to installing agents you
have to join up to do anything special
it's just ready to go out of the box if
you're on compute engine you just have
to install a short agent and there are
some tools in there for sending sending
arrows through to it but yeah I think
it's it's pretty cool I'm pretty excited
with how how it works yeah the thing
that I really like is whenever it
actually finds new errors and you can
you can of course set this up to match
your preferences but it can actually
send you emails so you can basically be
like on call and enjoy your life until
the moment will you get the email saying
well enjoying your style the hinge on
your life is done now go back to work
but ya know I think it's I think it's a
very useful very useful feature that I
hope people will use yeah I mean it's
not as sexy as some of the things that
we've we've done in the past on a shiny
maybe but it's sort of one of those glue
pieces that holds everything together I
could say it's almost as sexy and shiny
as probably messaging like logging yazyk
yeah a war when he works nobody cares
but when you need it you really need it
yeah exactly cool so I think it's time
to go talk with our friends from
instrument yep we're gonna have three
interviews back-to-back yep so enjoy
them we're gonna have first John Brown
then violet Pena and finally nicta Perez
and then we'll be back to talk about the
question of the week sounds like fun we
are joined today by somebody I think a
little specials of the conference well
thank you special a gentleman by the
name of John Brown I believe you're the
technical director yes I'm the technical
director at instrument from Portland
Oregon and I oversaw the development of
the playground experiences that all the
attendees have been experiencing cool so
the plague on experiences there is
though so there's a emo taboo the emoto
booth right there's the 360 toast a 360
data center tour there
the beat query and there's the query it
where it's the bigquery trivia game so
let's talk a little bit above them why
don't we start with admirable the motor
base is awesome tell us what is this
exactly and how do you how did you make
it sure so the motor booth is its
deceptive you think it's just going to
be a photo but if you walk up but all of
a sudden the person who's taking your
photo isn't just saying smile they're
saying frown show me some surprise
actually show me some anger what do you
got you got anger yeah and you get
through joy sorrow emotion joy sorrow
anger and a surprise is about the seven
stages of grief seven cents of course it
and then after you get your photos taken
you walk around the corner and instead
of just seeing a regular photo you get
to see a close up of your face it shows
all the landmarks of where your eyebrows
are the corners of your eyes your mouth
and then it shows you the sentiment the
it gets sent through the google vision
the cloud vision API the face detection
portion and it'll show the likelihood of
all of the four different sentiments
that it already had you go through so
you get to see a cool aura surround your
face so if you add very likely joy you
can see a really fun yellow halo burst
around you or if it's if you really
could nail that frown when they ask you
to frown you can see a fun blue shade
that goes up I particularly enamored
with this we may have possibly changed
the title image on our twitter account
for gcp podcast amazing both of us being
surprised you guys did a group shot we
did the two of us yeah it was fantastic
let me show you right now but this is
our near yeah that's a good one yeah you
can find that you can find that if you
go to twitter.com slash tcp podcasts you
will see both of us being incredibly
surprised one thing I love as well it's
not only did you let you see people let
people see it on the images around the
corner but you also when you tweet it
out you've got a gist there with like
all the data from the cloud vision API
as well as all the images that you took
in the photos exactly yeah so you can
explore the photo and all the data thats
related to its all in one place you can
sort of compare
trast between the different pieces yeah
very cool them I reelected the second
one that a lot of people were very
excited about is the 360 tour yeah so
are so our company did so the planning
of the actual 360 portion of it we
didn't actually do the video the in the
Google team did the internal data center
video for it but we sort of integrated
it with the rest of the playground
experience people come in look at it get
to see the behind the scenes of the
server that Google's finally letting
people see you know in a really cool way
good to see it in I don't know it's
probably about 30 feet wide you can
actually feel like you're standing
inside of the server it is pretty
amazing I have personally been a data
center and this is probably the closest
you can get without working at Google
yeah it was yeah pretty impressed with
the amount of stuff that we're actually
showing inside yeah it's really really
yeah very cool ah one more question
about the last demo that we have is the
bigquery at the cold queria query it
query and ! yeah I love the name yeah I
haven't had a chance to play with this
so tell me about what's the deal there
yeah so essentially we did is we wrote
200 questions they're sort of trivia
questions things like what state
mentions Velveeta cheese the most on
reddit or what musicians wikipedia page
was visited most in 2015 and what we've
done is we have a ton of public data
sets for reddit wikipedia g dealt and a
couple others that we have written
queries for that when you type in your
answer it actually puts it into the
query runs the query live there's a
really fun visualization that has a
visualized model of what's happening
behind the scene I'm in bigquery so it's
you know it's not a hundred percent
accurate but it's a really cool visual
representation of what's happening it
looks really cool yeah yeah and then you
get points based on the accuracy of your
results and there's two podiums you get
to play a friend or a stranger there's a
little bit of competition maybe you can
talk smack to each other back and forth
but it's a lot of fun so you're like
basically trying to guess what the big
data computation is going to end up
being exactly yeah I actually got to
play twice uh-oh so the first time I
but it was kinda cheating because the
first question that I got was i think it
was from stack overflow that maybe the
or maybe github mm-hmm oh you get hub it
was uh what is the language where yeah
what is the language where people
mentioned more Google mm-hmm and I'm a
developer advocate for go yes so how's
can I see right yeah so I got a hundred
percent on that one and even though I
wanted to let the other person win free
guest on the last question was what was
the most popular kitchen utensil on
Wikipedia last month I went with spork
how did you do 00 that was the point I
wanted to lose NS to one and the second
time yeah I got destroyed by sarah sarah
robinson from our team she destroyed me
at every single question is not fun but
yeah that was that was awesome an
awesome demo tell us a little bit about
your experience using the cloud to build
these demos what how was it sure so we
got to use the one of the really
interesting things is we got to use the
vision the cloud vision API when it's
still in alpha stage so we have to see
you know what it was going to be and we
got to try all the different features
early on and as we were developing the
emoto booth we got to try things like
the the object detection or the the
label detection we got to try the OCR we
got to try the landmarks we're gonna try
all these different things and we got to
craft the experience it in that we ended
up seeing based on being a have being
able to easily put all the images in run
through it get a bunch of that data and
sort of like look at it and figure out
what we wanted to do with it and winded
up going with the sentiment analysis but
we have things like we a giant cutouts
of hot dogs and we're like can we detect
the hot dog we want to give people
cowboy hats and put them into a scene
and it's going to check the cowboy hats
we tried a bunch of different things but
the cloud vision API was really great
even in the alpha stage and then the
only thing that it only got better as it
went we got to run more queries on it we
got to run more hits on the API and
there's a lot of fun too it was a lot of
fun to develop a physical experience
around
excellent and you found it I'm guessing
like a relatively easy API to use like
yeah absolutely yeah we we built a tool
we build a tool to just drag and drop
images into a web browser and about half
a day and we were up and running and we
could see the output and nice zoom in on
the faces were they were detected and
get all the sentiment analysis is that
tool open source so all of the all of
the tools are going to be open source
probably about in mid-april we rush to
get everything here yeah a little bit of
technical debt we need to take care of
my kin watch it yeah with in there yeah
all the tools and the emoto booth will
be up we're going to be hopefully going
i oh so anybody is didn't get to come
and experience either the moto booth or
query it here at the next conference
well we may be at the i/o coverage of
you that'll be great i would be awesome
that is great so uh tell us a little bit
about what you thought about the
conference i know you were really busy
building the demos but were you able to
follow a little bit the keynote so there
are there's so many people wanting to go
through the emotive booth we didn't get
to really see the keynote but one thing
that I will say about the conference
that I've got we've my team has gotten
to experience firsthand is going through
the emotive booth as I said you're
trying to get people to do joy anger
sorrow and surprise but essentially
everybody's going through and there's so
much happiness and joy and people are
smiling having a good time being around
cool people and learning a lot of
learning about what's next yeah that are
our historical screen is skewed with a
ton of joy even know what I'm trying to
get the emotions out of people for the
other things it's basically everybody
you're having a great time and I mean
that's like that that's exactly what you
want to see we have we have statistical
representation of people having a good
time yes we have data we have data on
that is a good problem to have that
goods could have yeah definitely that is
awesome well thank you so much again
John for taking the time to talk with us
we know you're busy today yeah I'm gonna
go back over there wonderful thank you
so much thank you to see you later right
so we're now with valid Pena one of the
developers from instrument the company
that created all of these cool demos are
surrounding us hi violet how are you
doing hi I'm great hey guys doing doing
great very excited to have you have you
here yesterday we
to interview John he took John Brown he
knows a little bit about all the demos
from a high point of view what demos did
you work on um so I was focused just on
the emotive booth um yeah using the
vision API cool which was an amazing an
amazing demo yeah we love this demo yeah
lots of fun tell us a little bit how was
the experience how did you come up with
the idea and how did it work yeah um so
we were looking for something to a
showcase the Google Cloud vision API and
we are looking for something that we
could fit into the conference experience
as like a really fun you know break from
more technical sessions and those kind
of experiences so we're trying to figure
out how to highlight it's different it's
different capabilities or you know how
to make that fun and interactive and so
we ended up landing on looking at facial
recognition um which is one of one of
the attributes of the vision API um and
so we got started getting really great
results with facial recognition and
sentiment analysis and so then we ended
up with this a photo booth that you walk
in um we help you make different faces
conjure up different emotions um and
then we analyze the points on your face
and your different anatomical features
and um then we tell you about what
emotions you're displaying in that photo
so was there a particular part of the
demo that you specifically worked on um
yeah so I was focused on the front end
so um everything that you see in the
displays um I had a large handin and
then I have some co-workers who are more
focused on the like back-end and
infrastructure sides of stuff and so
that's you know that was vital to
actually kicking off all the analysis
and experience after the photo is taken
so that was you know hooking up the
camera to you know getting everything to
run properly and getting all the back
end processing to happen so that we can
get your beautiful photos you did a lot
of like the animation and like the
display up on the screen that you
actually see as you walk around yeah
yeah there was a lot of just a cyclic
back and forth between me and the
designers about like oh well what if we
you know tweak this color and that
opacity and you know change those
timings and so it was really really
amazing there's a couple things that I
really a real AG one of them is kind of
subtle but actually so that aura that
surrounds you runs only the faces then
you can actually see ya so the picture
with you and three more people I thought
you were in that picture maybe not but
there were four girls in the picture
uh-huh and only one is looking forward
the others are looking backwards yeah oh
yeah the highlight of that single person
looking at the camera yeah at work um so
the way that we've had the experience um
work is that we want this I you know you
want this colorful visual treatment on
the photo but we didn't want to cover at
people's faces and so that's how we were
also bringing in the hexagon motif into
the whole thing right Joe hexagon around
the faces that you find but then of
course it only finds a one face it
doesn't know if it's a person if it
can't see your face um so that's how
sometimes we ended up with like you saw
if three people are turned around in one
person's facing forward that's the only
face it fine so it only draws the
hexagon around there and only analyzes
the emotions from that one face so we
actually also had some group shots where
I'm one person wouldn't be ready and so
totally by accident they will be looking
away or um in our testing someone was
sneezing well the photo was taken and so
her head was down and so it jus a
hexagon around like the other people in
the picture and then she was like
covered up by the color yeah yes so but
no I really I really like that as like
um actually just a really cool idea for
using vision API for like being able to
recognize okay these are the things that
we want to like focus on and so here are
the faces so we're gonna we're gonna
draw around that and frame that because
we know where they are in the picture
yeah something else really funny that
happened with face detection though um
and this wasn't a bug kind of a bug but
it was just really really funny to me um
some people here have security badges
with photos of them and so it didn't
happen to all of them but to maybe about
half of
um I guess the the light made it clear
enough like the flash was bright enough
the badge was angled forwards so it
would actually detect the face on their
badge and like these are really little
yeah right like that a little photo yeah
and um so most of the people so it would
map like there's another face in the
photo than it would zoom in on that face
and it was like this little blurry
picture on a card and so someone was
actually smiling really big in her photo
on her badge and actually kept saying
joy very likely for that it was even
sentiment detecting in that teeny badge
photo so I think it's hilarious um like
that happens they like it cool ah John
also mentioned that I finally there were
hot dogs involved twistys them could you
tell ya what's going on yeah um so uh
you're not gonna see any hot dogs in the
product um today but that was part of
the journey as we were figuring out what
the experience should be so I'm kind of
close to the beginning we were like well
a photo booth would be great cuz you
know conferences have a photo booth but
like we're analyzing photos so let's do
something with that so we were trying to
figure out what the photo booth should
do and so since um so the vision API has
so many like options of things that you
can try to analyze and some one of the
options is label detection um and it can
tell you what a photo is of in general
so like you pass it a photo of a farm
and it'll give you um you know labels
about what it would classify the photo
as in confidence scores and so we're
trying to leverage that and so we were
thinking like well what if we gave
people props and then we could get
labels going so like if you're carrying
around um if you have a hot dog for
instance then me something I should do I
just have a hot dog yeah just Oh what we
okay so we were printing out um foam
core props this was like a you however
many for footlong hot dog like no real
hot dogs no no an actual bow because we
think those would be a little bit small
but we're printing out like um you know
a huge hot dog boombox we were trying to
do landmarks so we were like we had a
sphinx okay big like I start going on
that so we were trying to do that maybe
so if you have a hot dog or like a slice
of pizza maybe it'll change the
background of the photo to like put you
and your group in a restaurant Oh or
something like that so we were playing
with that and it just got um got to
Harry because it doesn't detect um as of
right now anyway it doesn't detect
specific objects and say like oh I see a
hot dog yet you know this pixel by that
pixel oh yeah on it you have to it just
tells you what the whole image in
general is I yeah um so if you send it
the whole image of people even if
they're holding a hot dog it'll say you
know top guess is um you know group
setting or photoshoot actually but i
guess it was giving us a lot when you're
like oh that's that's not very
interesting come on um so uh yeah we
were trying to like slice up the image
and send through little parts but it was
taking on it was taking all just a long
time because we had to keep sending more
small images and check out those results
yeah again yeah and so at some point we
were just like oh I don't know if this
is gonna work right now but then we had
such other amazing stuff to dig into
that I think ended up being like really
really successful now there's a very
cool demo is there any other ideas that
you're gonna like to share we're like oh
yeah we thought about this other than
the hot dogs and yeah ignore something
right yeah so um yeah like I said we
also had landmarks and so something that
we were throwing around a little bit was
um so if you have landmarks um we wanted
to almost make postcard treatments I'm
so like yeah if you're walking around
with um with like the with the Eiffel
Tower right and that's in your photo
then like the visual treatment we do
like it puts you the city of Paris
behind you and then we have like a
greetings from Paris across the front
electron so yeah we were doing that when
you're trying to figure out like okay so
one person has you had the Statue of
Liberty and one person has the Arc de
Triomphe like what happens then like
where are we putting them in like in
what country and what's it yeah so we
were um Vegas like maybe yeah that's
actually we never thought of
I've been our default from any really
mixing really weird stuff Vegas yeah I'm
probably big so uh you know that was
that was really fun that was another
route that we kind of started going down
playing with that or maybe like oh we
layer backgrounds together we combine
city names like welcome to new Paris or
so that's that really cool um I mean now
what that would have been really fun
maybe we'll do some other just like
little fun side project that beard that
but see what you build for just be next
next year yeah yeah I'm very excited
about that this has been awesome thank
you so much yeah thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us yeah sure
haven't even you hi so we're here again
with again someone working for
instrument is amazing company that
created the very cool demo starts around
us today at UCB next we have Nick
subpoenas subpoenas yeah yeah cool that
works specifically on the query it demo
right yeah hi Nick are you doing doing
good could you tell us a little bit
about you what you do at instrument and
then how is it that someone came up with
that with his cool idea yeah um well at
instrument I'm a back-end developer and
kind of all over the place we have a lot
of front-end talent at instrument a lot
of graphic designers and front-end
developers so anything that's at all
devops or writing sequel for bigquery
that kind of the backend thing i'd hop
on that and i think the idea for
bigquery came from our creative talent
I'd instrument and trying to mimic the
family feud style like create a game for
for bigquery that's what the team that I
work on that's what we try to do is
create interactive experiences with
technology very cool so you mentioned
that you have back in engineer d have
you ever been before sequel is that
something that you put in your resume or
yeah no yeah definitely run a lot of
sequel a few jobs ago as actually
somewhat of a DBA a small company and so
glad there's a lot of things I need to
be done and
I was running back ups for the database
and running migrations and writing
sequel to try to figure out why the
database running slow trying to do
performance optimizations on it so
pretty familiar with sequel going into
the bigquery cool did you need to do any
of those like making sure that you
crazed optimizing stuff with the quarry
a little bit yeah we're trying to make
an interactive game and you know any
good interactive experience won't have
you sitting there for a minute wait he
had a great affection so in wrecked and
we're trying to support a lot of
features so some questions like what was
the most talked-about rapper on our
music in the last year we wanted people
to be able to type in Kanye or Kanye
West or J dash Z or J space Z and have
it all work and so the databases that
we're using had aliases and trying to
pull in those all the aliases for every
single you know musician and searching
reddit for that which taking like a
minute you know in the game slow and
chugging along to you type in your
answer and you're sitting there four
minutes waiting and we have and so
there's a lot of big query interface
actually had some like when you run your
query has an explanation of where time
was spent and shows you some kind of
portions of your query that took a long
time and was able to use that to figure
out what to kind of cut out of the query
to make it run faster to make it more of
a more a faster-paced trivia game was
this your press experience working with
the query oh yeah definitely just yeah
but pretty easy to pick up oh like
difficult anyway yeah just jumped into
the interface I think almost the entire
time I was just using the interface I
was created a co-worker of mine
eventually we wanted to we got up to
we're trying to create as many questions
as possible because that's something
else is we want people to be able to
stick around and play a few times and
that see the same questions over and
over so we're trying we're shooting for
200 questions on
so eventually once we got up to that
mini wedded just a huge database of
questions it became impractical to
manage my hand and so we're using the
API more but when I first started
playing with big queries it with the
interface and Philippe he is actually
using some of his databases he just sent
me some links to his databases and they
showed up on my account and just started
playing with them yeah ensuing sorry got
end and yeah just clicking on tables and
you can click and see all the columns in
the schema and just writing cyclone
looking around at the data Boston so I'm
quite curious to know what the process
was for coming up with those questions
people posed like I know you had the
data sets today like hoes the question
to you and then you were like okay now I
have to answer this question using
bigquery and then you go off and on to
write rinse repeat or once yeah is it
very that that was the most challenging
thing was coming up with the questions
because it's the data sets themselves
aren't that exciting honestly it's just
ready comments and github it pushes and
and I was so trying to create a question
that would make you laugh but was also
still possible to actually query it was
pretty challenging and the process
evolved a lot at first it was we had a
writer that was just coming up with fun
questions and strategist coming they
were both working on just writing
questions and I would go and see which
one of the witch of the questions that
they wrote were actually possible to
search and this is before I even really
knew the data sets that well and so I
take the questions and and have to
actually go see it whale this is queria
below i'm not sure and go try it out and
realize oh no there's actually kind of a
limited things that we can search so
then we changed it up to where i
reversed it towards like okay I've more
familiar with the data sets here is what
we can query try to make these
interesting and I think the one that we
had the most fun with was pulling tags
from freebase which is kind of like a
it's in bigquery it's more like a craft
database it's just a bunch of connected
I can go from like Tom Cruise was an
actor in the
movie and this movie was done the 1983
and in 1983 is the air that this
happened like this big connected graph
database and there's certain tags in
there so you can pull out like we have
one question about which 80s movie was
talked about most on our movies last
year nice and so we were able to get
like movies that were made in the 80s
and musicians and food ingredients in
breeds of dogs and things like that and
so that was I think discovering that
made a lot of fun questions because then
you're able to just search a lot of
these databases like Reddit is just text
as people typing the text there's no
structure and so getting a structured
data set and then being able to search
for certain categories within reddit
that I think created a lot of fun
questions so the combination of data
sets really yeah be able two things
missing yeah which was also tricky
because that creates a huge query
because you're kind of pulling like yeah
all of these movies over here searching
all of these comments over here for them
and just like multiplies you know you
have like millions of comments and
reddit they are searching for and
thousands of movies you're searching for
within each individual comment yeah
because something important to mention
is the fact that you really know what
people are going to write as either so
you don't even cache the solution or
anything so it's like every single time
that someone has to something you're
actually processing the whole millions
and millions of data yeah notice exactly
what we wanted to do with the experience
there's some talk about doing a multiple
choice versus typing in an answer and
you definitely definitely wanted to try
having users type in an answer because
then you get that feel of actually
hitting bigquery live and you can type
in whatever you want and it will go
search for it versus multiple choice if
you you know have like five choices and
you choose e it's your kind of thinking
well maybe they pull those answers you
know yesterday and it took five hours to
run the query and they take Anthony fake
it yeah you can kind of fake it but I
think it turned out great where people
can actually tell you know type in the
answer and they can type in absolutely
whatever they want they show this it
shows the sequel and thing that your
type they typed in is in there and then
goes and runs the query live I gotta say
I actually got a question which was what
was the most popular kitchen utensil
mom on Wikipedia yeah and i went with
spork yeah favorite kitchen utensil yeah
and the quarry actually worked I go to 0
so yeah I don't think it was prepared I
don't and then lots of people think
about sport very often apart right you
quite clearly yeah I like sports I don't
think I've ever cooked with I've used
this pork I don't think of cooking oh
cool so I have a couple questions about
what is about your questions ah this one
is uh what was you what is your favorite
question that you've written I think it
was the comic book character one there
was a lot of I mean that one there's so
many of them yeah we're pulling the
database like finding a list of all
comic book characters it there's like
six thousand or something and so it's
kind of fun to see random people come up
and just type in some random comic book
character that I've never heard of going
look them up and it's um you know side
character and some marvel comics girls
one guy specifically we hear you know me
and John we're trying to get people to
play hey when it plays no no no there
okay okay and then we go up we play and
he sees the first question is the comic
book character game or the comic book
character question and he immediately
say oh no anyways like now I want to
play everything's going to be you know
like maybe some kind of trivial pursuit
type questions and you saw the comic
book one he immediately was like oh
Batman okay you know it was ready to go
and I go what about what was the hardest
query to ride I why was the question
that came with the cop yes I think it
was the lot of I would think I would
saves the ones that we dropped there
were a few questions that I was working
really hard to get right and it was just
the data itself that wasn't quite
working out so there was a few like top
musician what you think is in there but
we kind of tweaked it that one I was
trying to do the thing where you could
type in Kanye or Kanye West or i could
type in glendan john lennon you know
there's a few aliases for certain
musicians I want people to be able to
type in and it was really slow trying to
support all the aliases
if some of the aliases in the database
were wrong so there's a lotta there's
many many many different occasions where
we're trying to pull musicians or actors
and someone completely unexpected comes
up so like pulling top musicians John
Cleese came up who because I think he's
in a musical hey and so technically he's
a musician and then he was the top
answer for the question he was the most
talked-about musician technically when
we wrote this query in our music because
his alias is friend in the database that
we're using and so when ever saw the
word friend it assumed it thought that
they were talking about John please so
he was like number one by far is like
number one John Cleese number two Kanye
West yeah we're gonna have to figure out
how to turn this right I'm sure John
place was very happy about that yeah I
get that yeah the biggest bomb there was
really just like yeah you need a data
set that he's given and you have them be
ready yeah yeah because because a lot of
times you don't actually know what I
mean we're not doing Nate and you know
natural language processing on the
reddit comments so it's trying to pull
data out of the comments where you know
what they're specifically talking about
so trying to come up with questions or
right questions to where there's no
ambiguity about what a user might be
talking about on reddit that was the
really challenging part very cool well
is there any any other question you'd
like to share like something was like
that was really cool I knew like to
share I think the speed of it I like a
lot of the data sets for github we're
doing all time so a lot so some of the
questions I got cut just because I guess
they weren't quite family-friendly was
like what programming language costs cut
is the most oh and that was with there's
like a list of like maybe 20 different
cuss words that were searching for with
github and it was like I think that was
the first one went to because there's
just so fun ever at the office was like
really having fun with that one and also
the poop emoji one what what was a well
as an angle you know what I think I want
to say it see cuz they're so hard to
write it was surprisingly I think they
were surprisingly happy people okay java
I think it was Java was up there Michael
um but it was the speed of it like it
went through every single event that
happened in github for the past like
five years like that just committed
species issue comments opening an issue
closing an issue like all of it it went
through all of it in like 10 seconds
passed out i mean that's when i first
started using it that that was a big wow
moment was just the speed of that you
have accessible to you know doing a
google search obviously is super super
fast and that's always been impressive
but now that it's been kind of turned
around and now you have the ability to
use that infrastructure to search
whatever you want within seconds that
one that was really really cool cool
very cool well thanks so much for taking
the time to talk to us yeah the from
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much to John violet and Nick for
those amazing interviews we have a bunch
of links in the show notes too so you
can see pictures about the demos and
videos and so on they're totally worth
having a look at so just go there and
enjoy and now we're gonna go for the
quest of the week yeah so the question
of the week is about the plumbing
manager and as I said it's the first
time we talked about it at all yeah I
think it's probably worth mentioning a
little bit what the plumbing monitor is
so deployment manager is a way to
programmatically and declaratively
basically say what infrastructure you
want to spin up on Google cloud platform
so maybe you want a whole bunch of
machines maybe you want a proven
eighties cluster maybe you want a cloud
sequel database and so you can write
these llamo files send them out through
deployment manager and it'll create that
for you an idempotent way cool cool so
it's kind of like a like Cooper Nettie's
configuration files where you describe
your architecture neither could take
care of your cluster but it's a little
bit it's a lower it's a higher level
we're describing the architecture of
your google cloud platform project in
seattle yeah yeah that is very cool
there's there's actually for some people
that might have used it before there is
also terraform by hoshi corp it's kind
of the same idea terraform works across
different platforms and cloud deployment
monitor
just for Google cloud platform so what
was the question then so the question
that got asked actually was by it by one
of our google cloud platform users who
was asking how you pass in variables to
deployment manager Oh interesting so if
you're writing your script you've got
say yeah more file but maybe you want
three instances of something in like
testing but you want 20 instances in
production how can you do that so how
did you do how do you do that so it's
actually reasonably straightforward one
of the things that deployment manager
supports is a thing called templates and
basically there ginger templates if
you've ever used python it's a standard
templating thing for python there are
those you know those yeah wonderful and
so rather than just writing a Yammer
file you write a ginger template with
these variable placeholders in them and
then you can populate them now we're got
a little confusing for the person in
question was they figure it oh maybe I
can pass in the variables on the command
line but instead of doing that actually
what you do is you end up doing a yellow
file where you import the template and
then when you import the template you
use that importers like custom resource
and then when you do that you can pass
in variables inside that ml file so they
just become like child elements within
that llamo will have it in the show
notes so you can see the example but the
templates are super super powerful
because you have the full power of
ginger behind it then you can simply
just pass in whatever variables you need
within that configuration so you might
have a test configuration for your
testing servers and then maybe a product
version of that as well for when you
want the 20 rather than the three or
four or five that is pretty cool I'm
looking at some of the configuration
files now and yeah they actually remind
me a lot of cube configs yeah it's um if
you look at the configuration files they
match up exactly with the API is the
rest api so we have to be able to create
staff and delete stuff so it's directly
in line with that they're pretty
straightforward to use once you get the
hang of them very cool well I think that
that's all for today but before that
maybe it's time to first of all thing i
will thank our listeners yep and remind
them how to contact us yeah so if they
want to reach us on email it's hello at
JCP podcast com if the 1i reaches on our
website it's GC podcast
if they want to reach us on Twitter it's
JCP podcast at deceive a podcast
actually sure if they wanna reach us on
google+ is plus GC podcast if they want
to reach us on reddit it / r / gcp
podcast and I think we're done or if
they want to reach us on slack its cash
podcast channel inside the slack
community always forget that one you do
are you gonna be anywhere special in the
next couple of weeks any new speaking
engagements coming up yeah much are very
excited about going to craft comp in
Budapest at the end of the month fair
enough so yeah very very excited about
that my first time in Hungary so if any
of our listeners somewhere run hungary
and Budapest let us know uh I'd be very
happy to say hi and maybe I can bring
your t-shirt ooh that sounds like fun
the end of the month I am heading to
Kentucky here in USA where bourbon comes
from I have never been that before so i
will be going to the vector conference
i'm hosting a gaming roundtable they're
talking about how cloud changes the game
that is on the thirtieth of april and
then i will be heading over to
louisville on my second to go to the
local GDG and talk to them about kuba
knees very cool sounds fun yeah it's
gonna be great have you been there I
have never been to Kentucky I'm kind of
excited near state yeah very cool well
thank you Mark for and I don't and
another amazing episode thank you very
much for joining me here again and talk
to you next week see you next week
you